hi I'm Eric Voss and Star Wars Episode 8
the last Jedi has ended production with
tons of new photos and a trailer coming
any day now hopefully and Mark Hamill
recently shared this interesting tease
about the film warning us to avoid the
1981 comic called the last Jedi which he
called spoiler Laden now it's possible
that Hamill was just joking here I mean
he is a bit of a joker
he also recently tweeted that a new last
Jedi trailer would air during the
October 9th Monday Night Football game
just to delete the tweet and lament that
no one gets his jokes but since I
already totally read this obscure
non-canon comic from the 80s I can say
without spoiling anything that there
could be some interesting clues that
connect to some things that we might see
in the last Jedi in a more thematic
sense yeah don't freak out I don't think
we have to worry about any serious
bombshells that Hamill's tweet implied
these are more possible character
influences in general story directions
that could take some form in the movie
but if you want to avoid any guesswork
or speculation yes possible spoiler
warning in this video okay I should
start by saying that the exact contact
specifics of the comic version of the
last Jedi can't possibly be the same as
the movie the last Jedi comic is no
longer considered official Star Wars
Canon so I'm gonna quickly sum up the
plot of it the story of comic issue
number 49 takes place right after the
events of a new hope Luke Leia r2 and
3po respond to a distress call on a
remote jungle planet rescuing Prince
dented of the planet of Elmore he has to
return to his planet so that his brother
Anna doesn't try to claim the throne and
change the planets allegiance to the
Empire now Dennett has a friend named
jedi daya yeah Jedi daya has brain
damage from the crash landing on this
planet all he remembers is that he once
had the chance to go through training to
become a true Jedi Knight but he never
did still he was force sensitive enough
to predict the political coup that would
try to oust Dennett luke and leia end up
returning them to vel more and they get
into all kinds of trouble ending with
jedi Dyess saving Luke by jumping in
front of a blaster bolt political order
is restored with Dennett ruling vel more
in support of the Rebel Alliance and
Luke departs with Jedi his body so that
he could
himmat space now obviously this doesn't
at all sound like the plot of the last
Jedi film none of the trailer footage or
set photos or plot descriptions on the
cast and crew suggests that Luke or Leia
or anyone else might get involved with a
power struggle or a line of succession
on a random planet as it faces pressure
to support an evil governing body also
we kind of already saw that in a Star
Wars movie so yeah I think it's very
possible that Hamill was just kidding
around saying hey look at this old comic
with the same name it's the movie that
clearly has nothing to do with the story
it could ruin everything and sure if the
last Jedi comic really was connected to
the story I don't think Disney /
lucasfilm would let Hamill keep this
tweet up or use the comics title for the
movie however I do think that the
character of Jedi di'ja despite having a
pretty goofy name is pretty interesting
and could actually be an inspiration for
things that we see in the movie so let's
dive in a theory time here let's revisit
Luke's expression when Rey approaches
them at the end of the force awakens
does that look like the face of a Jedi
Master who fully understands what's
going on no he looks at least a little
confused and listen to what he's saying
now in the last Jedi and yes sure he
could be suggesting that the ancient
Jedi traditions are obsolete and no
longer serve the galaxy as they used to
so that it's time for them to end or
another way of reading this is that Luke
doesn't totally have his wits about him
perhaps because he liked Jedi di'ja
suffered brain damage that has left him
with memory loss that's right Luke
Skywalker might have amnesia this could
have been caused by physical injury
after a confrontation with kylo Ren when
their relationship fell apart or perhaps
the result of emotional trauma like
Luke's failures were so catastrophic in
painful that he blocked out core
memories from his life all those tales
that Rey knows about Luke's life story
and his importance to the galaxy could
be a complete mystery to Luke leaving
ray and us frustrated as we still seek
answers about her origin and setting up
a potentially interesting dynamic as Rey
shares with Luke whatever bits and
pieces she knows about his story while
Luke shares with Rey whatever bits and
pieces he remembers about the force
Luke's possible amnesia could also
Blayne why he's been in exile for so
long he wouldn't think anyone would be
looking for him and he wouldn't know
where to return to now admittedly that
theory is pushing things a bit much so
another way this could go is maybe Luke
and Rey in the last Jedi will stumble
upon a new character that we haven't
seen yet some force-sensitive life form
similar to jedi dyad that doesn't yet
realize its full abilities and maybe
that character will be the last Jedi
that the title refers to and of course
if we're following this Luke Jedi diet
parallel fully I could see a version of
the story ending with a Jedi Dyess style
self sacrifice to save a younger Jedi in
training and an emotional farewell to
someone who is in this chapter of the
story at least the last Jedi come on you
can't tell me that you never consider
the possibility that Luke Skywalker will
die in the last Jedi he's an old mentor
figure that's what they do but I get it
it breaks my heart thinking about that
too and again I think if the last Jedi
comic from the 80s was too spoilery for
the movie there is no way Mark Hamill
would got him way with tweeting this
hall to remind us about it now maybe the
last Jedi just contains a reference to
the obscure character from issue number
49 a nod and a nod nod if you will but
I'm gonna throw it to you guys do you
think it's possible that Luke has lost
his memory and if you think this tweet
from Hamill was bogus
what other EU stories might have
inspired what we're gonna see in the
last Jedi let me know in the comments
below or tweet me at da boss or follow
new rock stars on twitter at new
rockstars for updates on our videos like
and share this video and subscribe to
new rock starts to follow all of our
Star Wars coverage and you can help us
make more Theory videos like this by
contributing to us on patreon big thanks
to all of our current donors especially
Lori Benning alright thanks for watching
bye